here's a peek at what guests had to say
after the show the panel is it possible
that the public rushed to judgment with
the indictment of Robert Zimmerman ooh
third rail that one is I mean I don't
know about the media I think certainly I
would never trust the media necessarily
on something where I wasn't there myself
and so I don't know what happened I mean
you know this guy could be a racist who
did I mean I certainly don't think that
law belongs on the books standard yeah
also that push I mean originally he was
essentially let off under under Florida
Stand Your Ground law and it was the
media pressure along with the public I
think that ultimately helped him get
indicted we know they the fact of the
matter is I mean it came out that he was
told not to follow this young fellow and
he did write young fellow ended up dead
so you know that looks that looks bad
but this is a night this is the United
States of America so he's gonna have a
trial it'll be a fair trial and then
we'll see how it how it comes out okay
Boras a says Romney is a [ __ ] I mean
Mormon huh
but wasn't he right when he said Russia
is still our main enemy you are too
stupid to watch this show sir I suggest
you watch the Paula Deen show I mean you
know the problem if I can get into this
a little is that when we're getting into
Syria yes
Russia's on the other side of that
conflict so we're kind of putting the
Cold War back into the microwave which
is not a good idea but no Russia should
not we certainly don't approve of
everything they do over there nor do
they approve of us and everything we do
and some of our stuff is is not perfect
but no they are not the main enemy cars
they are mrs. Christ Michael is it true
that there are agricultural gag bills no
I know in four states that will
criminalize journalism on industrial
food well they've been debated in
legislatures I don't think any of them
have passed quite yet oh they are there
are seeking decriminalize what was there
why was Oprah on trial remember that way
back go down to Texas that's right those
are in 14 states it's easier to libel a
head of broccoli than a person what's a
veggie libel in a way that crashes the
market and she did she went on she has
she on her show she has heard about mad
cow disease and she just said I'm not
eating another burger in my life and the
pinyon citizen the idea that you can't
say this is insane and these laws would
never survive a challenge well I in most
supreme courts but didn't you have to go
on trial yeah do a show from Xillia of
dollars defending herself
oh no Texas should be able to eat
unfortunately she won
because had she lost we would have had
the constitutional test we needed these
laws but these new ones these ag-gag
bells criminalize the taking of a
photograph of an industrial farm and
publishing it without permission
oh gosh wife's we're spreading sunlight
situation can't have that in America Bob
with the upcoming Supreme Court rulings
on affirmative action next week do you
agree with the Economist that it's a
good idea for it to end no I don't
either
yeah what's missing is that the
assumption is that the somehow the
playing field was leveled in terms of
race in this country that has never been
the case we you know we went through
however long the centuries of slavery we
went through the Jim Crow era then we
went through the discriminatory period
discrimination has not ended a lot of
people would like to believe that it has
but we have a black president oh man but
the fact that matter is you know one in
three black children in this country is
growing up poor a lot of black families
can't afford to send their children to
college and a lot of kids are going
through schools that are terrible
schools and then when they graduate they
get a diploma and then they get into
college they're not up to speed so you
know the argument I always use is look
if you look at the economic statistics
like they're like the average household
black household is worth maybe like
something 11 cents
cani dollar this is the white something
with with white I think with something
like the median household income is
something like 120 grand right I have it
correct there is a few variations on
black but the highest one that I saw is
that the median family wealth among
African Americans is $5,000
that's no money and that's the high
estimate I think it came from a Pew
survey right so it's so if you look at
those statistic of together you have to
come to one or two conclusions one black
people are inferior and that's why they
can't make much money right or there was
some sort of legacy right
not to mention and that for we need to
redress the right the legacy plus the
continuing discrimination there is still
a great deal of discrimination innocence
yeah they've done studies people go in
it with the same quality no questions
for a job and okay alright
why do you Josh why do you encourage
Republicans to continue trying to repeal
Obamacare sigh something to write about
[Laughter]
37 times I'm even bored of writing funny
anymore if I repealed 37 times most
recently a couple of weeks ago because
they said there's a new generation of
Republicans just got elected haven't
proved their bona fides their
constituents back home that they want to
repeal Obamacare so what the hell will
go for 37 I mean not well I know why
they're doing it because Obama is
defiant the defiant president got to
teach him a lesson
I wish the Obama was darling he
President Obama vote for me because I
just did this is crazy
the primaries are shooting themselves in
the foot they lost an election because
they've never brought enough appeal and
what is the house done we've got fetal
masturbation Food Stamp removal parties
they voted to Depot they voted to deport
the children of illegal immigrants
that's gonna win over the money might
win Paula Deen's vote but it's not gonna
win over the minority voters they I mean
we have to electorate now we have the
one that votes in the midterm election
which elects tea party and we have the
one that votes in the main every four
years which elected Obama and if you're
playing to that that electorate it's
it's stupid but if if you ever want to
win back the White House and any
intelligent Republican and there aren't
a whole lot in Washington will tell you
that look ultimately it's for our own
good we need to begin with immigration
reform then broaden out and appeal to
minorities but some are just thinking
about them well most of them are
thinking about the districts but you
know there's there's a demographic
reality I mean Lindsey Graham
the South Carolina Republican senator
said last week you know our party is in
a death spiral if we don't all the right
thinking Republicans are saying that I
just have to believe this has got to be
a tipping point I mean seriously the
fetal masturbation that should be it I
don't know because they're always
tethered to their base you know Bobby is
the base though what is the base is that
they're always they're always catering
why wasn't Sarah Palin the tipping point
why didn't they take their cue from that
away yeah every time you think there's a
tipping point there's none I mean Bobby
Jindal who ran back to stupid so fast
this week at the beginning of the year
when they lost their members the end of
last year when they lost the election he
said you know trying to be courageous
and it was he said the Republican Party
has to stop being the party of stupid no
there's a lot of stupid people in this
country and they need representation
that's your client base you own that
plus Bobby Jindal has no standing on
that issue so not anymore did you see
yeah but listen you could you could put
the same kind of red mate speech in a
Democrats mouth no equal fun that's
that's part of the problem if that's
part of the problem is that thinking
that there is this equivalency of not so
and there just isn't there just isn't I
mean not every Democrat is a prize we
all agree to that but you never find
somebody on the blue team who says the
kind of crazy [ __ ] that they say and
believe the kind of crazy should they
say I mean there are smart Republicans
who would try to get the people from the
tea lagoon back onto the reservoir
back onto the reservation but they're
not succeed iam and that's what Karl
Rove is trying to do he's like stop
talking about abortion were the
Republicans we I'm [ __ ] living okay we
gotta go thank you very much everybody
Real Time with Bill Maher and Friday
night at 10:00 ask bill and his guests
who are questions right after the show
at hbo.com